[Music]
okay
Indiana Jones back in the saddle
get back
the dial could change the course of
history
builds I've been looking for this all of
my life
[Applause]
G13
we loved Indiana Jones because we love
movies The Joy of those Adventures we
love the cause and effect the tripwire
of events all these pieces fit together
to make the lightning in a bottle of an
Indiana Jones film but also It just fits
Harrison like a glove
preparation was not really necessary
Harrison loves this character as much as
the audience loves this character so we
ask ourselves what could be the next
adventure and in this case it was what
could be the last adventure
we come to find him in 1969 the world
has changed around him he's retiring as
a professor and he's about to stumble
into an adventure sorry
hello
it's filled with awe and excitement and
danger and they've completely captured
that
[Music]
I felt good
and that we had made a film
that the audience deserved
I feel confident that we're gonna knock
their socks off
I've been looking for this all my life
[Music]